have you seen that clip from what is it
sex in the city going around no i've
seen it going around but i haven't
watched it yet i've been watching it
that show so much is so boring and
stupid but i wasn't sure was this a
parody of really sex in the city or this
what sex
sex in the city ruined millennial women
yes yeah i really like that so child so
childless millennial women are going to
be a huge problem going forward
they're going to be miserable
they're just going to be miserable and
right but the issue is that they're
going to be getting more power
yeah and they're going to vote and
they're going to vote and they're going
to be lawyers and they're going to be in
the doj and they're going to be judges
and that's going to be bad i'm just
saying when they're in their 70s they're
all going to vote for state you know man
like state funded
like elderly care of some sort like
they're what i mean to say is instead of
relying on family yeah and private
individual support they're gonna their
their only choice is going to have to be
some kind of more socialist or communist
which is exactly what was marketed to
them remember the obama
address you know this year
yeah yeah and then biden had one too
yeah it was like i don't know her
son yeah yeah and then what's nice is
that
i think this is what this is what women
are being sold women are being sold no
relationship right your primary
relationships with the federal
government right yeah so i think zoomers
are starting it's like zoomer
um females and and males in general are
looking at this and saying looking at
millennials and saying okay this is
generally a fail generation um you you
made really bad decisions some a lot of
which was you know due to external
factors there was a lot of crazy stuff
that millennials went through in their
formative years and that's true but at
the same time we're going to learn from
these mistakes and we're going to make
corrections very quickly a lot of them
are also going to be very pissed off
when they find find out how scammed they
were by everything yes
against it as well they're going to find
out faster they're going to read it you
know i hope they do find out fast and i
hope that it's not too late for them to
you know have families and don't be like
us
yeah and i want to say points for
self-awareness on the topic of sex in
the city this one of the stars came out
and said i really regret living the
feminist life i'm really sorry that i
don't have a family i'm sad that i don't
have kids i was like oh which do you
remember which one that was i don't
think it was kim catrell and didn't they
write her out or something probably oh
no way
i think they did i think she's not in
this one that's all i know about sexism
all i know is i was watched i was like
looking for something to watch one time
and i was like talking to my brother i
was like oh you know i'll watch sex and
city i never really watched that show
and he was like liz you're gonna hate
this show hate it
and i was like man i'll give it a try
everybody likes it i put it on i watched
like half an episode i called my brother
i was like you're right i hate this so
much i hate it so much everything about
this is pure hell it sucks yes and it's
it's uh it's not it has nothing no
relevance to the new york city that i
know remember evil evil cannot create
evil can only corrupt i want to okay i'm
going to read something that's going to
be offensive to feminists because i
often do
carl benjamin posted this on instagram
it's getting better it's a reddit post
where they where it's titled
attractiveness over 30. and it says hi
32 female have started feeling insecure
over the past couple of years as i see
more and more of my male acquaintances
in their late 30s and over dating women
in their early to mid 20s
i am by no means unattractive quite the
opposite but seem to have trouble
finding men interested in
age-appropriate relationships what is
going on can someone just what is going
on can someone just please reassure me
that there are men in their thirties out
there interested in women in their
thirties
maybe but this is not a new phenomenon
girl
libby take it off take away take it away
this is what happens my grandfather when
he was like in his 70s was dating a
woman in her 40s
come on like this is what happens
men can date anyone they want at any
point in their lives and the older they
get the more access to the dating pool
that they have and women like when you
fall in love with somebody and you're in
your 20s and you think to yourself you
know i really want to pursue something
else i i don't really have time for love
in my life right now i want to upgrade
have the love take the love when love
comes to you in life
accept it with an open heart and move
forward
you know grow together grow together
create a family create a life together
yes young men can't compete an 18 year
old guy struggles to compete against a
30 year old guy yes he has no job he
doesn't know what he's doing he can
barely grow a beard like come on but
unless you're unless you're kyle
rittenhouse okay he's gonna be fine yeah
he'll be good there there are some young
people who reach you know status that
you know faster than others but an 18
year old man and an 18 year old woman
that 18 year old woman is going to have
it's going to be a breeze she pops open
bumble or twitter or okcupid and she has
max messages and she can go through the
pick of the litter
18 year old guy is going to get nothing
right but those those those
apps are also creating are also part of
the problem absolutely because they're
they are expanding the dating pool far
beyond what it ever was was historically
speaking right and so you're going to
have 80 percent of the women going for
the top five percent of the men like it
was back when uh when we were tribal and
nomadic right but the pool was still but
the pool was small right right right
though
where people say to themselves like oh
you know this is my high school
boyfriend or this is my college
boyfriend or whatever and this isn't the
right time for me now i need to go to
graduate school before i can embark on
you know before i can accept love in my
life that's the stupid idea
you know when you fall in love like
accept it go with that well hold on we
have a super chat from john cordisco he
says love love libby sadly i'm too old
for her
my guess is he has no idea how old i am
nice
we we've done a bunch of segments we've
had a few guests where we've talked
about this phenomenon there was one
story from i think the new york post
covered and said women in their 30s are
struggling to find men who make the same
amount they do
and it's and it's and the funny thing is
it's really simple and i'm not i don't
say this to be offensive but boy does
this really trigger the left a guy who's
35 who's making 80 000 a year
can find a woman who's 24 and he's going
to be like hey i make 80 000 a year you
want to go to the movies or go take and
she's like wow okay he's got the ability
to
like have fun and a guy the same age as
her is probably broken in college
then a woman who's 35 he's going to be
like
but i can have any woman you know all
these younger women why would i you know
go out with you especially like you're
busy working all the time right
you're pursuing your career have fun
with that yeah yeah and like here's
someone who's young in college and not
working and once they have fun right
this this was the lie of sex in the city
this is what was pushed this was said
that you that you have to sacrifice one
for the other and you don't true you
don't and the other thing too i mean you
can have a career you can have love you
can do all like do them together team up
team up yes you know and make this
happen literally it's the plot of every
hallmark movie you know what there's a
reason that they keep making hallmark
movies right and those movies are awful
and they're all profitable and they're
all profitable we watch them i saw a
reddit too there was this guy and he was
like uh ladies would you date a garbage
man of course because i just got an
offer to be a garbage man heck yeah and
it's a lot of money but i hesitate what
i'm pointing at the podcast arm the
podcast arm
that was wonderful
it's fine what it's a chinese
marmalade yeah marmarated marmorated
stinkbug anyways the scream was
priceless
in this campaign office where i worked
in uh in pennsylvania years ago
and um he
like really got freaked out with him as
well so i had a little glass box and i
just used to collect them
and then i would and then i would hide
it in different places in the office and
then i would tell him it'd be like hey
can you you know grab some staples and
stuff that he would open up
be gentle with him if you hit him too
hard they release a stinky stinky yeah i
would put it like in his in his desk
drawer so what happened would the women
date the garbage man oh a bunch of women
were basically like a swoon of course
yes yeah i have a job yeah so he's a
good job and he with benefits and he
pulls down nearly 86 figures all right
yeah that sounds amazing and he has to
get up early yeah right and then you
know and he
also he was like this job will give me
weekends off i don't have that
yeah weekend's off yeah you know and he
eventually concluded the post was i'll
just tell people that i'm a delivery
driver perfect i'm really and he has a
great immune system
but there's no like this sort of there's
no shame in honest work yeah i if i was
a garbage man i'd be like i'm a garbage
man yeah yeah me too and you know i feel
very grateful for the ability to earn a
living
to work i'm so happy for that you know
yeah and it makes me sad that these
women have been sold the lie that they
can't have both well
you know we could actually we could
actually interview
there's there's someone else who's here
that we could interview that could
actually ask about this situation
someone i personally know who got
married in her twenties had her first
son at 22. went on to an incredibly
successful career come on come on
come on
chapter 7 lady here a very lovely lady
ladies and gentlemen it is my mom oh
snap my mom laurie hello
with me because yeah just coming out a
little bit yeah married fairly young had
jack when i was 23.
i had my associate's degree and i worked
at a
pharmaceutical company
microbiologist got a job
and i went and i got my bachelor's and
my master's
i had two children worked i just retired
for 40 years congratulations okay sounds
like you had it all yeah it's sure
turned out i just turned 60 but i have
two little grandchildren and i feel
young enough that i can run around and
chase them around which i just did
[Laughter]
wait until the best time to have
children it's never going to happen
because there is no best time there is
no best time that's something i wish i
have one son
if i'd known that there was no best time
i might have two
would you have girl talk yes do it right
check it out
trust me i mean i wish i could have done
part-time i did work full-time but we
had a lot of support you know yeah was
it the support was in the community
uh family that's nice yeah it's perfect
yeah yeah i really think that women have
just been sold such a lie that they they
either have to choose one or the other
and i think it's wrong i think that if
you find someone that you love you have
to find a way to make it work and if
that means adjusting your work schedule
you need to make it happen because
that's way more important than a job and
you know the thing too is like you know
it doesn't always work out but you still
have to go for it yeah you can you can't
say when love comes into your life you
can't just say no to it yeah and and
they've been told they have to right
because something else is more important
and self-fulfillment through career
you know that can be a thing or whatever
but it's never going to be
as fulfilling
you know as
having a team as teaming up as having a
family you know being a mom is literally
the best thing that i ever did and it's
my favorite thing ever you know
everything i do is like in service
that's pretty awesome you know yeah for
being a mom
to jack of course wonderful
but everything i do is like you know
that's that's the most important thing
right you know it's like raising my son
to be a good man yeah when you you got
out of height i didn't get your name
what is your first book
uh when you so you like you go to high
school and then get married and have
kids uh i got an associate's degree
right out of high school like vet tech
and i got a job
did you meet like the father of your
children while you were in school
so what did you like know him in high
school yes oh okay very cool yes he's
older than i said seven years older so
nice so at that time that was literally
what we were just saying my scandal yeah
yeah it is that's scandalous
yeah
that's literally what tim was just
saying though that's that actually
proves the point that and that you met
what 1977
give or take yeah same year star wars
came out um
that but that proves the point that
dad to you was more attractive than
someone who was your own age for a
variety of reasons right therefore more
competitive and a more compatible
partner yeah
that's true like this this is actually
just a traditional thing so sorry you
know
reddit lady
i'm not sure where we got the idea that
we have to be the same age as each other
i find that one partner having a little
more life experience is a huge advantage
communism that's a big deal oh communism
made us well so the the people who want
to create this uh they want to destroy
traditional culture and create this flat
blank slate society needs to eliminate
gender differences which are
um to a i mean
there are immutable and like on average
i should say
gender differences right they exist and
hormones play a huge role it's
fascinating to me that they can quite
literally say like oh we're going to
have an athlete perform in the olympics
as a trans athlete as long as their
testosterone is below a certain
threshold
so you're quite literally saying that
men who produce more testosterone than
women are affected by that and thus
there's serious biological differences
between males and females there there's
never i've said it before you know they
pulled that right yeah yeah yeah but
there this one i'll tell you what really
triggers really triggered the feminist
when i said there will never be
equality between men and women there
could be political equality like you
can't discriminate on the equality under
the law right for sure but the idea i'll
put it very very simply
if there's a man and a woman and they
both want to get a career and then have
kids the woman will always have to be
the one who creates that child which
puts them out of work for even a short
amount of time that disadvantages them
i'm not saying it means they can't
achieve i'm saying yeah i don't think
that's a disadvantage i don't think
having the ability to create and carry
life is a disadvantage i think it's an
extra it's an additional responsibility
women do have an outsized responsibility
for the furtherance of you know humanity
itself uh but is that a disadvantage
well it's just not like it's in the
workplace right is that a gift
of absence you know sure that sort of
thing but if you have to take even a
week off of work that a man doesn't then
that man has an extra week to do the
work right but i also agree that one of
the biggest problems is looking at that
as as being a disadvantage the idea that
a woman gets to have a woman women get
to have children yes it's like oh that's
so i'm so sorry that's going to hurt
your career's prospects instead of being
like talking about that's amazing
congratulations i i feel very strongly
about this as well because i feel like
we tell women in society that we say you
know and this goes back to abortion as
well we say that being a mother is not
something that's valuable that being a
mother detracts from your fulfillment as
a human being you know and we tell
people you know oh you're poor
uh you don't have a lot of prospects
being a mother is not for you you should
abort this child why aren't we saying
instead like motherhood is kind of the
greatest thing ever
and every woman can be qualified to be a
mother you know suck it up
woman up as they say you know and like
like do it do it and and respect
yourself and respect your ability to
give life if if you have the gift and
can do that you know not every woman can
do that
um and that's a tragedy for a lot of
women but
you know you can do this you can be a
mother if you're 17 and you're pregnant
you can be a mother you can do this you
know thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you